[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host style and sake
on super-pumped to be talking about
going beyond resumes we have the
co-founder and CEO of code signal
joining us Tigran sly on hello hello
thank you for coming on the show thanks
a lot for having me and I'm so grateful
that I stumbled across your content on
LinkedIn and reached out I thought that
it was very thought-provoking that we
need to figure out how to properly
analyze the skill sets of people
especially the technical talents of
people and then it'll care them with the
right ways to maximize that flourishing
into the world and so that's what you've
been doing the last four plus years with
code signal and we're gonna unpack that
in more detail I want to start things
off with this big history perspective on
reality so we find ourselves as stewards
of earth and we're all part of this
human experiment with your current
synthesis on this yeah no I think not
truce in this book it's called sapiens
birth history of humankind it's if you
haven't read it I'll recommend it it's
it kind of blew my mind when I sort of
started going through it I rarely read
books twice but this was one of the ones
that I was like alright this is too much
I gotta take it one more time to see
what it's like and I think as you read
through that book one thing you realize
is that it's really an experiment right
it's like there is this algorithm that's
runs through our DNA where we're kind of
like vessels that carried that DNA and
that DNA keeps constantly evolving and
sometimes evolving in ways you may or
may not want it to evolve and
history-taking sometimes in ways we may
or may not want to go I think it's
natural to assume that like things are
just gonna happen the way you know
they're meant to happen but it's not
really true
like I think one thing that they point
out in that book is that it's
questionable whether the evolution of us
becoming from hunter-gatherers to people
who were raising crops and like you know
staying home and getting their food from
their own making it was that good or bad
because really initially the thought was
like well if we have more resources
we'll do better but really what happens
it's like the quality of life suffered
people started just not getting enough
nutrition because they're reading the
same thing over and over again and a lot
of things happening which like all
sprouted from an initial thing that
seemed like a good idea but eventually
turned out to be actually a reduction of
the quality of life so I think like the
historic perspective if you look at it
is that you don't always want to say
like pick one thing and try to maximize
that because you never know where it's
gonna lead you it's always like a
fascination with our certain actions
what's the outcome of that action and is
that gonna benefit the human race and
everything around us or is that gonna
you know initially benefit but later
relate to like worse outcomes I love how
you use the word experiment because the
show is called simulation and when we
think about things from the perspective
of the is being an experiment and this
being there's a certain code that is
running right here in in our processes
of civilization and we get to pick what
is the best code how do we upgrade that
code how do we archive old code right
how do we keep upgrading right and so
that perspective on on reality is how do
how do we maximize the potential of
every mind that's birthed into the world
nowadays I have a question for you
actually now that you bring up the
simulation there's a you must know the
simulation theory where basically people
say we all live in an actual simulation
not just kind of like a hypothetical
simulation but an actual like we all are
inside of somebody's computer and this
is just a simulation of like let's see
what this looks like do you believe in
that you'll see your score screen once
with your score screen will appear and
you'll see all of your all of your
rankings from this right I'm just
curious do you believe it do you believe
this could be a simulation or do you
glad this is reality we asked that
question on the show every single show
and it's a it's fascinating hearing
everyone's takes on it and I'm very
excited to probe that question with
science okay super excited I think one
of the most fascinating ways to probe it
with science is gonna be when we just
run the actual code of our reality and
then press play right for 13.8 billion
years and then observe ourselves right
that will be I think one of the ways
that right you know I think will be
variable theories that somebody else did
it and we're in that experiment crap
yeah you never know if this is the first
or the next one so it could be multiple
also well to answer your question around
like why go beyond resumes yes what I
want to I want to get because this this
specifically your tag you know the links
are in the bio for everyone for code
signal as well as go beyond resumes org
the the why behind this yeah the resume
is old it's not an actual measurement
it's where you've worked it's your work
history right but to actually know what
you've done you need it a measurement of
a sexual skill set absolutely and I mean
anybody you ask any CEO anybody who's
been dabbling in this space everybody
says that like talent is the most
important asset we have right so like
it's the people it's the talent it's the
team that makes every company every
organization tick but the way we're you
know finding that talent evaluating that
talent this just saw it dated and the
reason it's becoming worse and worse is
that over the last thirty years there is
a shift in how we learn right like how
do we acquire skills because if you
think about education versus recruiting
education is how we acquire skills
recruiting is how we look for those
skills right now back in a day like 40
you know 40 years ago 50 years ago right
the way we really acquired skills is you
went to one of those handful of colleges
that actually were teaching you some of
those key skills and then you went and
work for it at some of those like
notable companies that kind of helped
you upgrade those skills so resume
seemed like a decent proxy right so you
put that on a resume and other people
look at it and like oh we recognize the
school that's kind of the only way
people learn Oh years of this company
exactly right I mean it was a reasonable
proxy you can't argue with that
but like over the last thirty years
it has flipped on its head with the rise
of internet with the rise of online
educational resources I mean I could be
in the middle of nowhere as long as I
have internet access and I know some
English that's like I can acquire skills
that are on par with like PhDs from top
universities because it's all out there
like inside just coded it's not just
coding I'm if you look at all of the
content that's available on Khan Academy
yeah yeah I can understand like you know
PhD level biology's just watching
Salomon's counts video and if I keep
practicing and working on it practicing
and working on it from a young age
exactly especially from a young age I
can build a skill level that's amazing
my resume would say I am a person in the
middle of nowhere
exactly no experience no school went to
Suns grundle Community College or did
home schooling so but I can tell you
about the inner workings of a cell at
the PhD level exact how do you pluck
that person out of that environment and
bring them into the field yes exactly so
the insight was that like at least for
the company itself for code signal like
we've got to start somewhere right this
for like developers it's highly
objective like you have the skill or do
you not maybe in other fields such as
like I don't know art I still think
eventually we'll figure out an objective
way to measure a quality of art not
there yet but first things like math and
computer science and accounting there's
a lot of objective scales and objective
measures and by is measuring it directly
right let's stop relying on proxies
school was a good practice it no longer
works people are trying to find out are
proxies such as like let's just analyze
your resume and find the right
combination of words and that might be a
good proxy it's not like let's stop
looking at proxies you couldn't measure
it directly just like I can say hey can
you lift this weight I'm gonna not gonna
say like have you lifted this before or
like who was your trainer when you were
lifting this like a lifting
can can I see you do it if you can do it
I have
tangible objective evidence that you're
able to do it and I don't know like it's
been a constant struggle and an
explanation to people that it's possible
because most people perceive that like
we're always going to be using proxies
to evaluate talent and my mission has
always been let's stop using proxies for
almost everything yes you can design
something like a flight simulator
because what is a flight simulator
flight simulator tries to measure your
direct ability to do the job right you
don't when you were hiring a pilot to
fly a plane you don't say well show me
your credential I mean you do sometimes
ask for credentials but you wouldn't
trust him a plane just because they went
to a good pilot school right you
actually have them do that yes
simulation and you have speaking of
simulation exactly every field right
that objectively measure the person's
skills
exactly and that's though that's your
long-term exactly oh that's cool yeah so
so coding is one place to start and it's
a good place to start because I mean
software engineering has been on of such
a massive rice it has enabled and still
continues to enable like different
economic improvements and whole areas I
mean they're they're calling it digital
digital transformation where almost
anything is being transformed by how can
you do this through software so like
coding is a is a solid place to start
that my dream is that one day we can
really like directly evaluate talent and
use that evaluation to like level the
playing field but in addition also to
provide motivation there is this recent
scandal with all of these celebrities
and people like bribing officials to get
their kids into the school people look
at it like oh what bad people and make
sure now gonna judge their character but
it's an it illustrates another point and
the point that illustrates is like how
dependent have we become on pedigree
that this people notable people are
tripping over themselves to get their
kids into those schools and to be able
to acquire that pedigree because they
know how much it matters whereas here is
a contrast I went to MIT I was lucky
right place right time right so it
helped me get that pedigree and get into
this world but MIT education is almost
freely accessible yeah lectures are open
yes
they might see OpenCourseWare you can
just go watch every class you have to
hold them everything's so good with MIT
EDX is such a great platform you can't
get that mighty level education even
better not pay $40,000 dollars a year
for it but no one does you don't see
people bribing you know officials to
like extract that it's just sitting
there and very few people are accessing
it which is insane
yeah but it's insane because they do
realize that that's not what's gonna get
them where they are going
like just acquiring the knowledge and
the skill is not the solution
unfortunately soon this will be changed
that's what I'm hoping because once it
changes it's not only gonna help people
who are already there it's gonna
motivate those who are not there yeah if
I know I'm gonna be valued for what I
can do I'll be way more motivated to go
and learn and acquire the skills versus
thinking well I'll just gotta get to
that College once I do I'm set for life
which only have 2,000 slots a year
exactly in that in the college and it's
insanely costly I mean student death is
such a right than international
competition - it's crazy
yeah the debt that we take on we're as
free of cost with an internet connection
and a computer can learn PhD level
across any field any discipline now and
then if we can adequately assess the
skillsets and plug them into we're
already approaching the remote work era
as well the gig economy right they can
even be working remotely on the projects
absolutely and just in common conversing
across the world on the advancement of
the project probably mates absolutely
they say the world is becoming smaller -
the technology because everybody's so
interconnected like we're probably
streaming life right now and people all
over across the world that are watching
it this wasn't possible three years ago
right so like that transformation is
just so incredible and I think talent is
the biggest frontier we have to solve
because human potential it's just
amazing it is can explore that human
potential I think we'll live in a
different world
years from that very different yes yes
okay I want to ask you this this
question so let's see let's let's take
it from this picture I like taking it
from this picture there's there's a
every mind is like a there's been a
hundred billion or so of these minds
that have built civilization and every
mind is kind of like a seed with its own
potential it's like its own permutation
its own combination of creativity that
could be unleashed but the social fabric
in many ways inhibits the seed from its
route of character and so it's our
objective to maximize the social fabric
to enable the flourishing of each seed
and then that creative potential that
talent unleashed on the world that is
going to solve some of the greatest
challenges have some of the best new
ideas what do you think about that
perspective and model it's such an
obvious idea yet so many people don't
see it right like they take for example
the Renaissance era ok people perceive
the Renaissance era most people as it
was just this magical time where all of
these geniuses happen to have been born
in almost the same cow around the same
time right so all of a sudden there's
this like da Vinci Michelangelo all of
those instantly same town that's not
true like what really happened is that
social fabric in a specific location of
the world where it was never possible
instantly turned into a situation where
it enabled human potential and it
enabled growth what really happened
wasn't those geniuses somehow happened
to be born in the same place same time
is that there was and there's this
there's a series of Netflix on this it's
the Medici series right now it's this
Medici family Greg learns that was
basically one of their main founders of
the family was obsessed with art yes
unlike most other rich people of that
time so he really created this
environment inside inside Florence yes
where this talent was appreciated and
from a very young age they took on this
very talented artists and they gave them
the platform yes to explore their talent
and that all of a sudden in the
of nowhere right you see this insane
talent flourishing and we still talk
about it it's been six hundred years
yeah we're still fascinated what they
did and that's not only one example like
I mean same thing if you look at Mozart
Beethoven but area same thing happened
where all of a sudden social fabric and
situations changed which provided this
fruitful ground for those seeds to
flourish and then boom we get something
that we've been marveling at for like
300 400 years the question is if we were
to enable that everywhere every day all
the time yeah yeah what would we have
what would we have in our hands yeah
not yeah not just a couple of them
Unleashed but we're talking billions of
them Unleashed do you think that the the
movement for basic income we and moving
into the automation age is one of the
solutions because Medici was a you know
obviously a patron of of Michelangelo
and da Vinci and whatnot and the more
that we can kind of give entrepreneurs
and artists their basic needs met and
let them pursue their creative desires
is kind of one of the keys to unleashing
that one of them so I think economic
stability is definitely one of the
things that's gonna unleash that but
it's not really the economic stability
that's like truly delivers that level of
talent it's it's the motivation it's the
learning yeah right so like it's good
the further together first you've got
exactly like you have to be I mean you
know the Marlow's hierarchy yes right
like if you're basic you know I got a
drink water feel safe have a house to
live in and have you know food to eat I
cannot think of anything else like
that's the basic human if that's not me
mad I can't do anything which too many
in developed countries do they still do
not happen yeah they still do not happen
but afterwards like what really explores
human potential is that first we've got
to provide people the motivation to do
it and that motivation comes a lot with
social environment that you live in this
room right so like why are Brazilians so
good at soccer
they don't have a soccer team but it's a
national pride it's a thing that you do
it's you live you're born with like your
heroes or soccer players and all of a
sudden your motivation level to like
practice every day all day to get there
goes on an exponential writes yes right
and that's how you get that incredible
talent coming out of that country and
they've also developed this sort of
system of like getting young kids into
it
practicing and like having very
experienced coaches who can constantly
provide it's called deliberate practice
yes we're creating an environment in
which you can do deliberate practice yes
get constant feedback practice get
feedback practice get feedback focus on
the things that you're not doing well
and just gradually improve your skills
yet the edge of the your level of
uncomfortability was that with it and
continuing that cycle of growth at the
edge for yourself and if then you have
to pass the the tens of thousands of
hours in this deliberate practice and
have really strong mentors have access
to the basic needs met and then
simultaneously the motivation the social
motivation right like being in the
middle of and again same with Medici
like because they've created this
environment in which there were all of
this artists they were almost like
competing and helping each other right
like it they pushed each other and this
was this like inspirational moment where
it's like that's why when it happens it
starts happening it starts spreading and
no not there's not one or two it's
usually like a bunch of people come out
of that and same thing happened in rush
I think where there is a school in
Russia that is producing amazing tennis
players and it's the same idea they've
created like an environment in which
playing tennis and becoming amazing of
it at it like Anna Kournikova I think is
one of the people who came out of that
school it's like they've created this
place in which being an amazing tennis
player is a is a is the ultimate goal
like it's you're a hero if you have done
that and that's what I'll like feeds
that motivation to keep doing it okay
so this is this is a
good amount of background now I want to
talk on assessing assessing the the
technical talent to start let's let's
look at that because soon it'll be
assessing you know all talent and then
plugging it into the right right right
yields and whatnot but on on a technical
assessment level we have some images and
this is the
which aspect is this is a coding
assessment for who this is for the
recruiter to see right so like this is
something like for developers you know
think of it Oh interesting this is your
this is where you're showing the scores
exactly okay here let me let me let me
take a quick let me take coos app so so
I'm I'm doing your coding assessment sir
and then after I do your coding
assessments I get what you have as a
coding score similar to the FICO credit
score 350 so you get a score and you get
a report like a credit score and a
credit report and you show me where I
can do better
exactly so like you as a person taking
that assessment you'll get to know how
you can be doing better in which areas
you need to improve I as a recruiter get
to know what are how good are you in the
skillsets that I'm interested in and if
you were at the place where I know like
that we're looking for regardless of
your background regardless of your
experience
I will move you forward and get you into
the conversation another analogy like
FICO is a good analogy the way FICO is
different is that you don't take an
assessment to get a FICO score it's more
like your activity that data of your
activity of like using credit is used as
a way to generate the FICO credit score
another analogy that's more similar is
like the SATs or the TOEFL exams but
better
like for example SATs are just multiple
choice and a lot of the times it's not a
realistic simulation whereas this one
it's like an SAT it's standardized it
generates an actual like score that you
can compare across the whole world yeah
but it's more like hands-on where you
can actually like it's more like a
flight simulator and less like a survey
that you fill out and that you get
multiple-choice questions yes okay so
then then you would this is this is very
cool now not only our technical is
technical talent able to see where they
can do better and continue using the
assessment tools that you have to
develop their their skill sets but then
also the recruiters can see which
candidates they want to reach out to for
interviews right away and then they can
then see which candidates have strong
soft skills emotional intelligence
skills which ones yeah with their
interview process and how well they're
will they'll be teammates and how well
they can do independent work and focus
and all that other kind of stuff quick
on your analogy you had earlier of of we
want you know can you pick up the weight
right is you know we want to see you
pick up the weight here's you know you
see scores of eight forty you're picking
up the weight how do you know what
weight they're picking up right how do
you you cuz there's so many ways
computer science yeah yeah actually
knowing that process knowing machine
learning absolutely
yeah it's it's a great question the way
it's done is AC technology is good there
because how does the city works there's
general SAT and kind of establishes a
baseline do you know most of the stuff
that is usually taught in high school
right and then there is subject tests
and the subject tests are supposed to
probe at specific verticals so we've
kind of done the same right so we have
like a general coding assessment which
is like a baseline of can you code do
you understand the basics of what makes
software engineering software
engineering and then there is
specialized coding assessments that dive
into each specific verticals so there's
like one yeah right so there's like
JavaScript specialized coding assessment
it's like Java specialized coding
assessment there's like a data science
specialized coding assessment right so
like each one and dives into the
specific verticals and then companies
choose which wants to request so it's
not like you know everybody comes gets
assessed and then there is a pull you go
look at this is not a sourcing solution
this is more like hey I've gotten
thousands of people who just applied for
my job how do I know who to talk to
right now companies either ignore that
list or they just go through and throw
away 95% of the resumes because it
didn't have the keyboards they were
looking for and then do you invite the
other 5% and then they complain that
they don't have enough candidates I'm
like well you cut ninety-five percent of
the people who applied what did you
expect
instead we're like everybody who applies
ask them to do code see no certification
use like if you want just general coding
abilities and then to complete GCA if
you want specialized knowledge if you're
hiring for a JavaScript developer
send them to complete the JavaScript
specialized coding assessment once they
do and the beauty of it is that they
don't have to use it once like once I
have that's just like my credit report I
can do use it with other companies
whereas today even if you're using an
assessment solution it's somehow very
unique and customized to you which makes
it difficult to put results in
perspective to look at it as like so
what does that even mean when I get this
result and it also for candidates means
that like every time I apply for a job I
have to do your own specific assessment
which is very annoying because I'm
playing for 20 jobs 20 people send me an
assessment I'm like okay hey I have a
life yeah yeah and and this this is this
reminds me a lot of the machine readable
formats that we want data might be made
available in write so they get out of
the data silos and then it all becomes
in a normal machine normalized machine
readable format right and so this would
help tremendously then with only having
to do a coding assessment and get your
your your skills assessed and developed
over time and get rank up your scores
and then all of the companies are able
to use that as a general right right
yeah format that they can then say oh
you're really interested in pursuing a
biotech or neuro tech organization or
how about a blockchain your
cryptocurrency organization and then you
just get plugged into the ones that
you're most interested and it can tell
you whether you're qualified or not -
because eventually you can imagine we
could tell you as a somebody who's
trying to go work at like a well-known
companies like here's where you need to
be in your skill set because that's also
missing information right now when I
want to go let's say I'm fascinated with
like self-driving cars and I want to go
work at like a self-driving car company
and have the company in mind I'm like
what skillset do I need and at what
levels do I need that skill set it's a
complete unknown right now we need to
put knowns to these unknown exactly so
that at least you know what to prepare
for like what do I have to do to like go
do what I'm hoping to do and right now
maybe the best is like eeks Electrical
Engineering computer science from
top universities kind of like what they
yeah say is maybe the yeah II D and
that's a whole other topic because
education and like industry are so
disconnected disconnected from a little
hey this companies won't be and there is
like no connection but again that's like
recruiting an education have a very
close connection because acquiring
skills looking for those skills
acquiring skills now they're
disconnected so it's it's almost as
though every single industry position
should have a unknown skills that they
want to see and then there should be an
assessment platform like a code signal
that can get the the candidates to the
right levels that they're asking for and
then they can come into those
organizations exactly and then everybody
wins because less as a candidate you
know but you have to do you know what
are you ready you're not job search
process is less frustrating your resume
is not getting tossed away and as a
company you stop getting stuck in like
chasing the two percent that doesn't
have pedigree and you can actually tap
into the 98% who's getting better every
day the more educational resources
available the more there are people who
are just amazing at what they do yes so
their resume doesn't say that and
there's so many other interesting
butterfly effects that happen from this
because not only does someone from
around the world that's doing tons of
like MIT OpenCourseWare stuff end up or
Khan Academy stuff end up getting
plugged into this organization and then
what ends up happening is they get the
economic benefits from that from from a
more developed part of the world
potentially for them to invest that
money into their family right their
community right their ecosystems there
and build those up faster which is very
cool and then also the philosophies and
ideologies from that other part of the
world kind of get baked into the teams
in the developed or area as well which
is a cross-cultural pollination and it
creates a diverse perspective because
one thing that happens is that like it's
great when you know a group of people in
a specific location they motivate each
other and they create
that food fruitful ground to like grow
talent but that also creates its own
like biases people become more like
minded and they're just kind of like
think of things in the same way that's
right but the fact that the world is
becoming smaller and smaller so
technology it can enable the whole world
to be just like very motivating and
fertile ground for all of this talent to
flourish and enable more diverse
perspective more diverse opinions and
more diverse backgrounds yes which will
make everything better
yes and that's where we'll have our
civilizational dialogue back and forth
updating the code the best aspects of
the code and companion pushing forth um
Ronnie let's move to the next images I
want to showcase the other couple here
see interesting so you have a little bit
of visualizing that you guys do as well
here so yeah teach us about this vision
yeah it's like a data-driven analysis
right this is like I called his resume
3.0 like resume 1.0 is the paper you
know resume that just says you know what
you've done where you were and doesn't
capture the essence resume 2.0 is more
like the online resumes that are popping
up with social aspect added on top of
that that makes it a little bit more
dynamic constantly maintained instead of
getting outdated but it still doesn't
it's not data-driven it's not objective
enough all right this is the resume 3.0
because it's highly objective highly
data-driven so it says like what's your
overall score what's your stress if I
was to put like one number to represent
your current level what would that be
which is like usually the maximum of all
of the different things that you've done
so in this case you took like a
JavaScript specialized assessment then
you took a general coding assessment and
then you got a 790 on one and 840 on the
other one that's why it takes two 840
and puts it at the top because that's
the thing that you're the best and so it
takes the max and puts that up there as
you're like overall according score
interesting and then it dives into like
well what are some of your course go
versus developer right it'll hold the
speed really high on the problem solving
and
and all of this is measured very
directly if you go to the next picture
that's like look what I usually called a
flight simulator like this right so like
this is like a real coding environment
and with whites of you exactly like a
flight simulator for an intersystem gets
them to do what they are supposed to do
not asking multiple-choice questions
not saying so where did you go to school
yeah all of those are like indirect
measurements and then you had this
really strong post that you had just a
couple days ago now about how one of the
one one of the people that made software
that Google 90% of the Google employees
use but did was asked to make a
whiteboard yeah it was after a reverse a
binary tree on a whiteboard so like it
just shows how much of far away that is
from a flight simulator right yeah first
asking to invert a binary tree weirdest
person skills and strengths lie
somewhere else I mean it's part of
software development but it's a very
specific part of it so like getting
asked to do that it's like I don't know
asking like a commercial pilot ooh I
don't know try like a fighter pilot
position like try to fly one of those
fighter jets right which is I mean it's
still a pilot job but it's a very
different one right it's like can't
expect me to do it and like they asked
him to do it on a white board which is
which I don't know why but today show us
how to land a plane on a white board
right so like if we didn't even give you
the plane we said like you know my
friend evil eye oh yeah you know fighter
jet using this like white board like can
you sit on that white board and simulate
how you would fly it the person has to
be in the environment where their skills
can actually be assessed I actually need
to sort of set up like the flight
simulators you've seen the setup right
they don't give you like a chair and say
okay this is your flight simulator right
they actually have a real very realistic
set of it feels like you're in a plane
you're not in a plane but it feels like
you're in a plane so you can showcase
what you're able to do and that's kind
of where we've been going with our
IDE this is called an ID we're just
anding for integrated development
environment created development
environment that's where that's the
plane of engineers this that's where you
do exactly that's the cockpit where they
do the creative development environment
and then there's also the collaborator
exactly so like on top of that there's
like an automated testing aspect but
we've also enabled like a collaboration
aspect where if I'm trying to interview
you right like going off of that post
that you've mentioned yes so that one is
not supposed to be out I mean they're
they're like actually having having a
one-on-one conversation and trying to
evaluate your skills yes but even then
we promote this sense of like give them
the actual simulator you can observe
them do it that's fine it doesn't have
to completely happen automatically and
this is one of the solutions this is the
interviewing solution right we have like
that certification which we talked about
and then we have an interview solution
but give them the tools that they're
used to to show you what they can do
you can still observe them through video
call or just sitting next to them or in
a kind of like an asynchronous
environment but you have to give them
the tools that they're used to yes
otherwise they're gonna fail and then
you're gonna discard them and miss out
on a on a credible person potential yes
in the last image that's it great okay
so on the way out let's chat about one
thing that came up for me that I really
wanted to ask you was you have this way
of measuring people's skills and
assessing it and it's so fascinating to
me thinking about how you can parse so
much data online to be able to as people
are already doing making psychometric
profiles of people so to me it's
fascinating thinking about the potential
of parsing people's github x' ahead of
time you can also parse people's social
posts on a Twitter platform or whatever
and you can actually see by the words
they use their worldview is it centric
is it multivariate are they taking in
dozens of worldviews or are they binary
towards one person
right what are your thoughts about that
it's a very interesting question because
there is a lot of parallels around what
it is and what it isn't humans usually
and I'm sure you would relate to this
like they have their online persona and
they the way they'd like to be perceived
and then the way they really are and
that's why I don't think proxies such as
will parse your online activity and make
a judgement about you work interesting
because just like the resume right like
you usually the representation of it is
different right over the last 20 years
there's many ingenious ways people have
found a way to like game the resume make
it look nicer and like misrepresent some
fact same is happening with github
the more people realize that like Oh
companies are looking at github to make
a judgment about our skills well I'll
just use somebody else's code and put it
there but all of a sudden the whole
thing is discarded but that also is not
working anymore because you can get as
on YouTube you can't upload it's almost
like it's it's block chained in a sense
it's it has its own unique identifier to
your vet long-form content or even your
short from content you can trio blowed
it somewhere else so if that identifier
can be made for like a github they
haven't done it yet not yes if they
could like just like you do contract
like you know does this post look
similar have you been like downloaded
from somewhere else posted it somewhere
else I think for video it's easier
because it's like you know if the
graphics seem to match if the sound
seems to match I've ended in a fight
like a piece of software is a lot more
complicated so it's hard to say whether
it's original or not but again same
analogy applies everywhere psychometric
analysis I can bet you if you analyze
most people's Facebook's you would think
they're a completely different person
than they really are because people just
they have a different view of like what
they want the world to see for better or
worse right so like analyzing their
posts and just looking at the scraped
result it's still gonna be a proxy and a
lot of the times on inaccurate proxy and
maybe in the future it won't be as we
become more sim
a trick with our personal life and our
online life and it just becomes less of
a of a always my the best self and you
know you can have some of those photos
of you look like less less beautiful
okay and that's you know that's
basically a wrap I want to do you know
it's fascinating thinking about the
unleashing the creative flourishing of
every single person and adequately
measuring their skills and plugging them
into the right technical environments
and and and this is a very very exciting
project code signal okay just two quick
questions on the way out you asked me at
the beginning so now I want to ask you
are we in a simulation well such a good
question you know the answer is I don't
know and to be honest I don't care
because I think when I think about like
are we no simulation there's a pretty
high chance we are because like what are
the chances that were the first ones
that have figured out that a simulation
is possible there's a pretty good chance
somebody before us figured it out and
we're just living in it why do I not
care how are my actions or the way I
live gonna change you're still gonna be
your best I'm still gonna be doing what
I'm doing today let's say we're living
in it how does that really affect you
know how I go about life and how I make
certain decisions really doesn't make a
difference
so I find it it's fascinating to think
about how we could be in a simulation
how in the future we can create our own
simulation we shouldn't be really cold
yes to see but just like if we are in a
simulation doesn't really change much if
we are ever gonna create a simulation of
human history whoever is gonna be living
in a George not really gonna care see
grant last question what's the most
beautiful thing in the world what's the
most beautiful thing in the world human
talent and you know potential I've
always been fascinated by watching human
talent and human potential flourish both
on a global scheme like building
solutions and driving movements to to
make it grow but most importantly I've
also been doing just on my own like
mentoring people taking people from
where they are to seeing their talent
flourish it's been sort of like a side
project in 2008
for me and I always love to see you know
incredible humans go do incredible
things and it's it's really beautiful to
watch what about the octopus they're
pretty talented aren't they I mean human
beings good come on sure octopus is
beautiful too I'll give it to you the
unleashing of the full animal plants
kingdoms talented talent and potential
different type of beauty different type
of beauty it's Iran what a pleasure this
has been thank you so much like what's
thanks for having me this has been so
enriching I think there's gonna be a lot
more of this assessment the proper
assessment and and really maximizing the
the full potential of these Minds into
the world until its upset I love it I
love it making these unknowns more known
this is so so beautiful everyone thank
you so so much for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below check out
the links to code signal check out the
links to go beyond resumes go and check
it out on the bio below also huge shout
out to Ron Vargas for producing and
directing thank you very much we love
you Dennis thank you for being here as
well with the team we much love much
appreciation for you as well everyone
support the artists and entrepreneurs
that you believe in we talked about it
in this episode it's so crucial around
the world support them maximize their
flourishing our links are below to
support us as well help us grow help us
prosper build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much and we will see you
soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]